antes de aplicar a la escuela de derecho
los estudiantes realizan un examen al
que llamaremos exter como abreviación y
antes de aplicar a la escuela de
medicina los estudiantes realizan un
examen al que llamaremos exm & también
como abreviación a continuación tenemos
un resumen estadístico de cada examen
así es que como podemos ver por acá la
media del examen de derecho es 151 y su
desviación estándar es 10 mientras que
para el examen de medicina la media es
25.1 y la desviación estándar es 6.4
juan realizó los dos exámenes obtuvo 172
en el examen de derecho y 37 en el
examen de medicina y ahora nos estamos
preguntando en cual examen consiguió un
mejor resultado
así es que ponle una pausa a este vídeo
e intenta averiguarlo por tu cuenta
bueno como yo lo pensaría es que no
podemos simplemente comparar estas dos
calificaciones porque los exámenes no
en la misma escala y tampoco tienen la
misma distribución pero si podemos
utilizar esta información que tenemos
por aquí podemos empezar suponiendo que
los dos exámenes tienen una distribución
normal o por lo menos una distribución
suficientemente parecida a una normal y
aquí tenemos la media de esas
distribuciones entonces como yo lo haría
es pensar en cuántas desviaciones
estándar se aleja cada uno de los
resultados de los exámenes de la media
de cada uno de esos exámenes podemos ver
que juan obtuvo una mayor calificación
que la media en ambos exámenes pero la
pregunta es en cuál de estos dos se
alejó más desviaciones estándar y vamos
a ver si podemos encontrar esas
cantidades
aunque hoy vamos a empezar con el examen
de derecho en el examen de derecho
obtuvo 172 puntos entonces vamos a tomar
su puntaje 172 le vamos a restar la
media de ese examen 151
y vamos a dividirlo entre la desviación
estándar que es 10 entonces 172 menos
151 esos son 21 y lo estamos dividiendo
entre 10 nos queda 2.1 en el examen de
derecho juan obtuvo 2.1 desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media por
encima de la media también lo podemos
ver como un puntaje z aquí juan obtuvo
un puntaje z de 2.1 por encima de la
media pero bueno ahora vamos a ver cómo
le fue a juan en el examen de medicina
juan obtuvo un puntaje de 37 pero la
media de este examen es de 25.1 y en ese
examen tenemos una desviación estándar
de 6.4 entonces pues vamos a ver tenemos
aquí 37 y le restamos 25.1 esto
11.9 pero tenemos que dividir entre la
desviación estándar que es 6.4 y esto
pues no sabemos exactamente cuánto es
pero sí sabemos que es menor a 2
entonces basándonos simplemente en esta
información podemos concluir que a juan
le fue mejor en el examen de derecho que
en el examen de medicina también podemos
calcular esto solo que para eso sí voy a
sacar la calculadora a ver 11.9 entre
6.4 es y bueno vamos a redondear a los
primeros dos decimales
esto es 1.86 1.86 aproximadamente
entonces otra vez con esta información
que tenemos aquí podemos decir que le
fue mejor en el examen de derecho porque
en este examen obtuvo un puntaje con más
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media aunque estos valores están muy
cerca entre sí si por ejemplo
redondeamos estas cantidades al entero
más cercano
entonces diríamos que obtuvo
aproximadamente dos desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media en los
dos exámenes así es que nos queda ya una
enorme diferencia entre estos dos
puntajes pero si queremos verlo de una
forma más precisa a juan si le fue
relativamente mejor en el examen de
derecho aquí obtuvo 2.1 desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media mientras
que en el examen de medicina obtuvo 1.86
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media pero si estuviéramos hablando en
términos generales yo diría que le fue
más o menos igual si por ejemplo aquí
hubiera obtenido dos desviaciones
estándar pero en el examen de medicina
sólo hubiera obtenido una desviación
estándar por encima de la media entonces
si yo diría que le fue mucho mejor en el
examen de derecho pero listo terminamos
con este ejercicio